after a slew of issues with the pc  version of batman arkham knight Warner  Brothers has announced the cancellation  of the mac and linux versions of the  game I'm Lucy and welcome to this  cancelled gamespot news update a  developer from Warner Brothers confirm  the news on the Arkham Knight steam  discussion board writing we are very  sorry to confirm that batman arkham  knight will no longer be coming to mac  and linux if you have pre-ordered batman  arkham knight for mac or linux please  apply for a refund via Steam no  explanation has been given for the  port's cancellation but remember that  Arkham Knights PC launch was plagued by  a host of problems when it was released  in June last year so did you pre-order  the game for Mac or Linux or are you not  surprised at the port's cancellation let  me know in the comments box below bra  the latest Gotham goings on make sure to  keep it gamespot